people are really sick and tired with
the performative nature of
a lot of legacy media because the
journalist isn't really oriented towards
finding truth what they're oriented
towards is signaling to other
journalists
signaling to everyone else that they're
still on their side
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissinger
and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
delighted to say we're joined today by a
reverse guest we've just been on his
show and here he is
talking to us as the founder of rebel
wisdom he used to be a journalist
and documentary filmmaker for bbc and
channel 4 for many years
devil fuller welcome to trigonometry
thank you it's good to be
in the other role it is it's good to
have you another role i thought we had a
great productive conversation
on your show and uh you know actually
maybe we can reveal
a little bit of how our connection
started which was you got in touch with
us
saying i've got a bit of a story to tell
so before we get into that very
interesting story
just tell everybody who are you how are
you where you are
what is the journey that leads you here
sydney talking to us yeah
so i'm a journalist filmmaker
i thought about this just before i came
i think i might be one of the last
people who actually got their start in
journalism via cfax
which the americans watching will have
no idea what that is but i think some of
the brits will
so tv before kind of the internet really
existed you pressed a special button on
your remote control
and you got up these kind of little
hidden uh pages so i worked for bbc
south and cfax
uh trained as a video journalist
and then ended up with channel 4 news
for many years mostly doing foreign
affairs for channel 4 news
and then i started making documentaries
and the reason that
i guess we're having this conversation
is because
i began i sort of made the move from
the kind of mainstream traditional media
into the alternative media in about
2018 with rebel wisdom which started
with
a documentary that i did with jordan
peterson and then has kind of developed
into
an interest in the intellectual dark web
and also in the topic of sense making
and the thing i'm really interested in
why i'm really interested in this
conversation we had a great interview
the other day
like what are what is what is this sort
of
alternative media space what are the
what are the opportunities of it and
what are the challenges of it and i
think that's a really like it's a
question i wrestle with a lot
like what are the positives and also
what are the negatives
because i've got a strong sense that
there's a lot of negatives from the
traditional media like there's a real
sense that it's becoming performative
it's becoming
a little bit more ideologically captured
it's becoming increasingly sort of
corrupted especially in the states i
think the state's in a much worse
situation than we are in the in the uk
but if we're seeing that fail
is the alternative media going to take
over how is it going to take over
and what are the failure conditions of
that alternative media
and how do we pursue truth in a kind of
post
um in an alternative age and sort of
post mainstream age
because i do have this sense that these
institutions are breaking down
increasingly fast
partly because of the the the rise of
digital media the rise of alternative
media we're getting all of these
different perspectives
which is really valuable but i'm also
kind of worried that we're losing a lot
of
um the ability to discern truth like a
lot of the checks and balances that we
built up over
over years decades centuries we're
losing
and what was great about our interview
that we did the other day was that
it was really like we had a real good
back and forth
of kind of challenge and disagreement
and that's really valuable that's really
something that
i don't see enough of and that's
something i'm concerned about so i just
wanted to say thank you for
kind of introducing um that that was the
the nature of the interview were going
to do and then how it played out because
and i called it walking the talk on free
speech which i think you did
and that's something that i really
respect and value well we appreciate
that and thanks for having us on the
show
and we'll talk about the mainstream
media and also the alternative media
later on
uh because i think that's a very
important part of the conversation but
let's talk about the interesting story
that i teased at the top because
you made this documentary called the
glitch in the matrix
and it was uh covering uh the jumping
off point is
is the kathy newman interview with
jordan peterson but it explores a lot
more than that
uh first of all just tell everybody a
little bit about that and then maybe
you start to get into what happened once
you made that
yeah and you've seen you've both seen
the doctor yeah yeah so
and it was very good by the way yeah it
was really yeah it was it
so the back story is in
2017 so i was still sort of working as a
documentary maker and
doing freelance shifts mostly at channel
4 news
um which kind of ties into the cathy
newman have you worked with her directly
yes yeah um i mean everyone as a
producer i was kind of i'd
write scripts and we'd kind of i
actually messaged her directly after the
jordan peterson film came out to say i
thought i really liked
the way they sort of had this like um
sense of
you had a sense of like they mutually
respected each other by the end of the
interview there was this sort of
subtext that i saw and i thought was
really really good i'm so actually
messaged her straight after
after it um but going back to 2017
i've always had a real interest in
philosophy in like
spirituality transformation religion
and always been a little bit frustrated
that you don't get enough space
like the framework in legacy media is
really kind of narrow
and i'd always kind of thought there's
more to it than that there's more
frames there's more perspectives there's
more um
there's more than we're being shown
through like the legacy media and the
mainstream media frame
and so i pursued a lot of my own
interests
a lot of uh stories about like
psychedelic therapy and
these in these kind of like fringe
things i think are really valuable
really interesting that might
change our culture at some point in the
future psychedelic medicine being one of
them um but
in 2017 i first discovered jordan
peterson and my immediate thought was
wow this guy has the message that is
just going to go viral
i just had this sense of like this is
exactly what the culture needs right now
because
we've lost so much of like traditional
values it's been kind of
excluded from like the the kind of i
call it like a low resolution grand
narrative of the liberal media
it's like frame those things out and
it's like jordan peterson just had this
kind of like
archetypal force almost of someone who
was like
channeling something or coming with more
than just his
his own personal perspective and i think
a lot of that has to do with young
um the the psychologist young talked
about kind of the power of the
collective unconscious the power of the
archetypal
and he was really kind of bringing a lot
of that into the into the culture
and that has a huge force a huge power
and i've done a lot of work
around young as well i've done a lot of
study of you and i trained as a
counselor
and i could kind of see this is
this is really vital and it's also like
i'm also aware like the new atheists the
sort of sam harris richard dawkins had
this whole stranglehold on the culture
and it was very difficult to get
when i was a filmmaker it's very
difficult to get films made about kind
of religion or spirituality all of these
kind of
things because the new atheists pretty
much all the commissioning editors know
that they're going to be
attacked by the likes of dawkins if they
commission something that says
that's on a kind of spiritual topic so
to see someone come along
take on the new atheist on their own
turf
and basically i'd say beat them like if
you looked what happened online
all of the sort of sam harris fans are
sort of saying oh actually no there's
to dismiss centuries of religious
thinking
is really naive and suddenly you had
this sort of like
you're an idiot if you think that
religion's got any truth to it to you're
an idiot if you think that there's no
truth in religion i think a lot of that
was down to peterson
so i kind of looked at it and i thought
there's the cultural side there's the
kind of
um political side of peterson but i was
way more interested in like this
the jungian side the synchronicity the
his kind of yeah this sort of sense of
a completely different perspective of
who we are and what we are as as
human beings was something he was
bringing so like this guy
and so i flew out to paid for my own
ticket flew out to see him in toronto
saw one of his bible lectures and then
got an interview with him the next day
um went to his house interviewed him
about
jung about synchronicity like that was
the main thing we were talking about was
like
this idea of synchronicity which is um
synchronicity would be defined as like
coincidences that have a deeper meaning
when something happens it's like oh the
universe is trying to tell you something
or there's there's more to it than
than is immediately and you kind of
follow those synchronicities in your
life i think as you start to kind of
navigate by them
um but yeah so we talked about
synchronicity and how these kind of
strange coincidences
have a deeper meaning and i started
editing the documentary and then
literally one or two days after i
brought that documentary out the start
of 2018
he was on the caffeine that he had the
kathy newman interview
on channel 4 news where i used to work
for
around 10 years with kathy newman who i
used to work with
and it's like that is a synchronicity in
itself and i was like
what on earth is this about i watched it
and thought it was as i said i thought
i thought it was a really fascinating
piece
i thought there was so much going on in
that one interview
at first i tried to i got i was in touch
with jordan i was in touch with kathy
and i wanted to cut i saw them having
this
increasingly bad tempered falling out in
public
and i hope that they could then stay in
contact and jordan wanted another
interview to talk about why this had
happened and
kathy was resistant to that or kathy
didn't want to go the channel 4 news
basically kind of
pulled up the shutters and didn't want
to go there um
jordan was still keen to kind of have
another interview about okay why did
this blow
up what is it which i thought would have
been a fantastic interview
to sort of say there's all of these
different layers of
the alternative media clashing with the
mainstream media this kind of
old tired way of kind of gotcha
journalism all of
all of these things just came together
in one then kind of you've got the sex
dynamics you've got the kind of gender
dynamics it was all just
there's so much there and so i tried to
kind of
bring them together behind the scenes
for a while that wasn't working so i
then thought okay what do i do
okay i just put it all into this
documentary which became glitch in the
matrix and glitch in the matrix
looked at it was subtitles uh jordan
peterson the mainstream media and
intellectual dark web
and it just looked at everything that
happened since 2016
the rise of trump the sort of like naive
as i said like the low resolution grand
narrative of liberalism that was
starting to get all of these holes in it
and then like the clash between
alternative media and mainstream media
and all of these different
layers that i just put into this
documentary with
about the kathy newman john peterson
interview um
and it's done by far it's by far the
most
jordan peterson uploaded it to his
channel where it's still i think now the
second most popular film he's ever put
out on his channel
it's got about five million views there
it's got another million views on
on the rebel wisdom channel and
i'm still proud of it it's from it's a
certain period of
of time but it yeah it just felt like
it was a i mean i don't know if your
viewers would respond to this kind of
word but i felt like it was kind of
channeled it was it was just sort of a
it was it was a stream of consciousness
thing of just like okay i've been
thinking about the stuff for like two
years
and tried to get it all into this
documentary but the interesting thing
with the documentary was
it still felt incredibly current even
though it was from four years ago
you still felt as if in a way we haven't
really moved on
we are still wrestling with these issues
we we're still wrestling with these
problems
do you think that we've moved on at all
or have we just remained stagnated
and in a way not knowing how to escape
the problems that you
you know that you brought to the surface
there yeah it's a really really good
point i think
i think we haven't i mean this is this
is the kind of tragedy of the post
of the of the trump presidency as i
think the trump presidency was in many
ways a kind of like
it was a [ __ ] you to kind of liberal
like there was a button mark [ __ ] you in
in i think brexit and trump were both of
that like our societies are too split
and there's this kind of subtle
or not so subtle hatred of like this is
kind of
world view it's like we're so inclusive
of absolutely everyone from everywhere
apart from those people who don't think
like us
and unfortunately those people who don't
think like us are an awful lot of the
population and there's sound reasons why
they don't think like
us or like them and so yeah i think
there's almost been no
or very little i think i think there
probably has been some but
very little learning about like why
trump happened
why brexit happened because i think it
again i'd use a jungian
frame and a piece of sodium frame i
don't think
we've read we've wrestled with the
shadow
like the shadow is like all the parts of
ourselves that we don't want to admit or
deny or repress
and there's so much of like trump is a
perfect example like he has that
reaction because
he's all of those parts of yourself that
you don't want to admit
and i think in so many of these places
like
we're in a time where we're gonna have
to wrestle with all of these shadows
and we're not doing it like we haven't
done it we haven't worked okay why did
it happen
because the question is why did it
happen it's something to do with with me
and if we don't accept that um all of
these people that we're kind of
rejecting that we're
judging that we're um demonizing our
aspects of ourselves we're never going
to get through
and that's the kind of the key kind of
realization i don't think
many people went through after trump it
was just this sort of sense of
opposition rejection and very very
little learning
and it's true in kind of personal it's
true in
any of our sort of personal lives if we
don't learn the lessons
we're going to be forced to learn them
in more and more difficult and more and
more
catastrophic ways like things start
falling apart if we won't learn the
lesson of
a certain negative pattern that we have
or a negative kind of belief structure
that we have
then it's just going to keep coming up
and it's going to come up worse and
worse and worse until we learn that
lesson
i think generally that's where we're at
in society is i think you're right i
think
i think that's in a way it's a tragedy
that the documentary holds up so well
because i think it shows that we haven't
really moved past
that much and do you think part of the
using the term the shadow
part of the shadow of liberal people
is the belief that they're right and
there's an arrogance about that
and if you go against them you're wrong
and therefore you deserve derision you
deserve to be mocked
and once that happens you stop having a
conversation
yeah i think we all suffer from that but
i think it's it
i think that perspective is inch is in
shadow
it's that's kind of the liberal shadow
because there's this paradox of being
open to absolutely everything being open
to
all all genders sexualities races
and i and that is obviously necessary
like that's a necessary thing but then
there's this hidden shadow bit of like
yeah but secretly we reject all of those
people who don't think like
bigoted deplorables and that's the
paradox i think that we're still
wrestling with
so i think it is it is true but that's
in shadow for
for kind of like the as i said like the
low resolution liberal
world so you make the documentary yeah
and uh the documentary i wouldn't say
was
you know super critical of anyone in
particular actually i thought it was
quite balanced it was a good piece
uh and what happens from there so
in the aftermath of that so there were
some criticisms of kathy newman
in there um although i tried to balance
that with saying not not unreasonable
given the interview and how it went
yeah yeah you know if someone's missed
five open goals in the match you sort of
go
maybe they didn't have the best game
yeah i think that's fair enough
yeah um but also i tried to give the
context that she was kind of thinking
about a five-minute interview she wasn't
thinking about half an hour interview
she was thinking about five minutes cut
down
where she was sort of which is another
factor in the kind of contrast of like
alternative versus
like we're now in a long form
environment where you can actually kind
of
dig in a little bit more and unpack
complicated ideas
and that whole kind of sausage making
factory of the news putting something
into three or five minutes is just
it's just completely unfit for purpose
but yeah so i did say in it that it was
an
ongoing car crash for channel 4 news
for channel 4 i think and i knew i was i
knew i was i knew it was very difficult
to go back in i've been working in
channel 4
in channel 4 news a few weeks before
that i've been
continuing to freelance there on a
fairly regular basis
and i knew it would at least make it
difficult to go back into the newsroom
that would be quite embarrassing or
difficult to be going in after having
put that out
um but all of my as soon as i'd done
that
the freelance shifts kind of dried up
and then someone came to an event
about a year afterwards and told me that
i was a guy i've been banned from itn
when he um when he came in he said oh i
told him i was coming to this event i
said oh he's the guy who's been banned
from itn
so that kind of and i kind of knew it at
the time that i put that documentary out
i did kind of
i wasn't i wasn't naive i knew that it
was probably
going to make things difficult at least
and maybe ending my
um career with
channel 4 news and making it potentially
difficult to work in
the tv industry i think i don't want to
over
overdo it but um yeah i knew it i knew
it would sort of
it sort of puts me on i sided with
jordan peterson i guess ahead of my
current employer
at the time is is the way that i kind of
but it was a huge opportunity like i
don't i don't regret that
because rebel wisdom and this kind of
new and fascinating exploration and the
alternative media started from that
moment
and so i don't regret any of that at all
but just jump in
why did you do that because that could
be seen as an act of self-sabotage
you know this was your bread and butter
this is how you put food on the table
why would you go essentially go against
your employers
and support jordan peterson um
i think because i took so seriously
like obviously i was really highly
influenced by jordan peterson at the
time still
a huge fan of his work and i took
incredibly seriously and still do
his injunction to tell the truth like to
tell the truth
no matter what and and the paradox
or the the the great thing about that is
that
it has work i'd say it's worked out
right i'd say
it has um yeah it's been a fascinating
exploration
of from following jordan peterson and
and
look like a lot of the first films that
we did were about the jordan peterson
phenomenon like what is it about
his message right now what does it say
about the culture
what does he we kind of called him a
one-man lightning rod for the culture
war
so it was just this sense of which i
think i've always had anyway but it was
just a sense of
it's the right thing to do it's the
right thing to do to
i think i've got something to contribute
i think it's the right thing to say at
this moment and i think it's
that that feeling of following
that feeling of following truth
to me feels like
i'd say i've made that a priority in my
life and i've tried to kind of
live to that as much as i can um while
also being aware that
it can be very you can never kind of
tell yourself that's why
that's the only reason you're doing
things because you're gonna end up
bullshitting yourself and
um we've all got yeah
self-aggrandizement and stuff like that
is something
i'm wary of but it is something i've
tried to make a
a priority and i i trained as a
counselor
and i know and and this was articulated
by jordan peterson as well it's like
the value of counseling the value of
personal growth is orienting yourself to
truth
it's speaking truth it's orienting to
truth and it's
it's building on that and i truly
believe that that's our only hope
i agree and it's interesting to me
because i hear in the way you talk about
it
a lot of how we think about comedy
because we've
been not quite the same but in a similar
way
we've pursued the truth
by doing this show and as a result of
that
how many friends have you got left in
comedy mate
no no he's not my friend exactly pretty
much right
and there's no question that our
opportunities within comedy
the comedy world the comedy industry
have been massively curtailed but
i hate talking about it because i don't
feel a victim of that situation
we went into that with our eyes open we
knew what happened we thought
pursuing the truth was more important
and let's be honest we've been rewarded
for it right we have a show that's
successful it's doing well
so none of the three of us want to go
and just poor me i got cancelled for my
you know because that didn't happen
right
but at the same time there's a bigger
thing at stake here which is
less so david fuller constantly kissing
francis foster more
why is a massive media institution so
scared of being criticized
they quote unquote ban you why is that
normal
do we want media institutions that do
that shouldn't the pursuit of truth be
the fundamental value of that
institution and that implies
a plurality of viewpoints yes i the
thing that i was
i mean i would still say it would
probably have been quite embarrassing or
difficult for me to
go back in there and do freelance shifts
after putting that out
like i don't know if i would have wanted
to go back and do do that
anyway um just on a personal level of
kind of like
hi hi i think you're an idiot
yeah um but the thing that i was most
disappointed about is i thought kathy
could have done a really interesting
documentary
like investigating like what happened
because i think kathy's got a really
interesting story seeing it from her
perspective she
she was a political reporter for a long
time um so that's kind of why she's got
a lot of that sort of combative style
like trying to catch out politicians
and she'd also worked in westminster
which is
kind of some of the places like with a
really strong old boys network and kind
of one of the kind of
vestiges of real kind of if you want to
say that there's
yeah in in politics i mean there there
are still
um very out of outdated attitudes
kind of and old boys clubs etc etc and i
think
she could have exp she could have
explained that i think it would have
given people more sympathy and more
understanding about where she come from
and how she's she'd succeeded as a as a
journalist
but also i think she could have then
gone into like what is the reality of
the gender pay gap
what is the reality of like if you value
truth more than anything
then i think i think i think she should
have
done that like it would have got a huge
amount of viewers but
she'd also and i'm not this may be
unfair and
be more than willing to have the
conversation with kathy if it if it is
she's watching me i'm sure
but also i think there's a danger
because she'd also established herself
with a certain perspective if you look
at kind of
she was writing a book about feminism
effectively
she was a big campaigner about kind of
the the gender pay gap and stuff
so i think it would have been maybe
difficult for her to go into that
into that exploration if she may have
come out with a different view than the
way
when the one she came in but i think i
thought that was like
that for me was a no-brainer because it
was been such a kind of cultural moment
and then to kind of examine that and try
and find out the truth of the things
that she was putting to jordan peterson
i think would have been a really that
would have been a really interesting
documentary but isn't that just a
recurring theme
of people not wanting to examine their
own actions their own beliefs their own
prejudices
in order to help them grow yeah and
we've seen
we saw brexit trump but we've also seen
it with channel four
yeah and i mean this is a little bit of
a segue into
the thing i mentioned at the beginning
because i think this is increasingly
important because
if the failures of the existing media
structures
is are like systematic or they're
they're structural
yeah um i think the failures in the
alternative media
universe are individual because we're
all becoming our own brands
and like if you look at on twitter or
even on youtube
like most of the failure conditions and
i kind of followed
the intellectual dark web i followed
like these alternative sense making
networks
and most of the failure conditions there
are
there are narcissism they're like
audience capture
they are the way that conversation
becomes performative
they're attracting an audience and not
wanting to let that audience down
they're all of because the nature of
social media and the nature of kind of
what social media is doing to us that
tristan harris talked about in the
social dilemma is it's basically hacking
all of our
worst aspects it's playing on our
narcissism it's playing on our desire to
be liked it's playing on our
um the way that we have certain views to
appear
because of how they appear rather than
what we really think and i think we get
this kind of gap open up because
between what we truly believe and what
we want other people to think we believe
all of those things
and that is where my concern about
the alternative media is because i think
we all have those
we all have those kind of um negative
characteristics and i think
they're being increasingly weaponized
against us in
the in the social media landscape i want
to get into that i just like to say a
trigonometry we don't have that problem
because we let our audience down
all the time and by the way like and
subscribe exactly
hey francis do you like martians well
i'll work with one don't i
would you like to have an immersive
experience with a martian are you going
to get me drunk on the vodka
near my side last time you wish
no there's this great new immersive
experience in london based on jeff
wayne's
the war of the worlds i've heard about
this the audience reviews have been
incredible
it was rated one of the top 20 things to
do in london
at night and 98 of guests recommend it
the experience features a cast of 17
characters
12 live actors plus a mix of holograms
projections
and vr of west end stars you feel all
your senses fired as you cool
slide and weave your way through 22 000
feet
of immersive action including 24
extraordinary scenes
and having to escape 300 foot martian
machines
and the evacuation of london it is fully
compliant
with covert regulations and they're
offering 10
of standard weekday tickets with our
special promo code which is of course
trigger all you need to do to take
advantage of this fantastic
offer is go to the war of the worlds
immersive.com
that's the war of the worlds
immersive.com
and experience a world where we're being
invaded by martians
which is still better than being in
lockdown follow the link
in the description and i'll see you
there
before we get into the problems with
alternative media we're not going to shy
away from that at all
let's you talked about the systemic and
structural problems with the mainstream
media now
they've been talked about endlessly in
these sorts of conversations
as here's the problem
where does it come from that's what i
want to know why did the media suddenly
get broken the way it did
i think i think we're in a slightly
different situation in the uk than we
are in the u.s
like in the u.s last year we did a
series of films
called what the [ __ ] is going on
what was that about um it was mostly
about
so there was a whole series of like kind
of major incidents within
so many american media organizations
there was the
the james bennet had to leave the new
york times he was the common editor who
commissioned that
op-ed uh by tom cotton about
troops on the streets i think barry
weiss then then left
andrew sullivan left new york magazine
and matt taibi
kind of left-wing journalist talked
about he was aware of at least like
10 revolts within newsrooms
and in the states the way that that was
written up mostly by barry weiss was
that
there's a new generation of um
journalists who care more about harm
than they do about truth effectively so
a lot of the
a lot of the criticism of the tom cotton
op-ed was it's putting uh
other it's putting journalists of color
at risk on the streets which is kind of
a bit of a leap
to to make that point but effectively
activism in german journalism a
different conception
about what journalism is for and a
different set of values and there's this
kind of real
generation gap but because of the nature
of that generation gap because of the
nature of those
attacks and the nature of the criticisms
they're very hard
to to argue against and brett weinstein
will talk about kind of how powerful
that particular world view whether you
want to call it kind of weaponized
wokeness or
social justice activism or whatever
inside institutions is very hard to
defend against
and so i think that like the new york
times is no longer the paper that it was
in many ways no longer the same
organization even though it's got the
same
kind of thing on same name on the on the
last head
and i think america is further down that
line than the uk
from what i can tell but i think it's
partly and then you've got this other
kind of factor of like
i think it's also financial like because
there's less and less money there as
well
you've got a lot of people going on to
sub stack you're losing a lot of kind of
really good journalists from
from the institutions as well because
they're leaving and setting up on their
own
so i think that's kind of increasing the
kind of decline
of the of the media and then you've got
this sort of sense of
journalists basically the world is
getting more and more complex but
they're still positioning themselves
relative to other journalists
but there's a group thing that comes in
most of the time they're positioning
themselves in terms of what they think
other journalists are going to think of
them
than than necessarily following the
truth but i don't think it's
i don't think i often find myself in the
position of
kind of saying it's not as bad
like i'm sure you'll be aware like
there's a hot there's a huge anti-media
um undercurrent on youtube especially
which i understand where it comes from
and i have some sympathy for it but i
think it goes too far
because most of the journalists that
i've worked with in the past have been
um very conscientious
very driven like they could have made
more money in lots of different other
areas
but there are systematic failings and a
big one is
who watches the watchmen it's kind of
this idea that
over time journalists have been used to
being kind of
the the people who judge the people who
decide the people who are the
gatekeepers but
we're not really asking themselves
whether that's
um whether they're qualified for that
effectively or who gave them that power
in the first place
like power that responsibility i think
becomes corrupting
and now there is more scrutiny i think
on media than there was
and that and again i say it's not as
it's not
catastrophically bad and i think a lot
of good journalists are good
but they're are systematic flaws with
the with the system that i think
are becoming ever more clear and do you
think part of the problem is
what you've just said but it's also when
a business because they are businesses
and they're struggling to monetize
themselves and they're struggling
to be relevant they're automatically
going to go for the lowest common
denominator
because it will ensure clicks and view
it in views and all the rest of it
yeah no it's a really really good point
and it's one i shouldn't have missed out
thank you that's what i'm here for mate
awesome
and that's that's part of the that's
part of the economic problems with the
is that and that's that's to do with if
you put out
articles say you're um the new york
times it stops being in their business
interest to challenge their audience
because especially you've got a
subscriber model it's much easier for
someone to be like oh you just put out
that
article that said jordan peterson wasn't
a monster i'm gonna i'm gonna
unsubscribe
so they're increasingly the business
model is increasingly rewarding them
playing to their base giving their base
what they want
not challenging them the more they
challenge the more
it's not in their financial interest and
i think that
they're subject to the same pressures
that i think alternative
creators are i think it's often i think
that problem is often worse in the
alternative
environment because it stops being in
your interest to kind of really
have a kind of 360 degree set of
perspectives
um but yeah i think as as it spirals
down in the smaller and smaller pie i
think you just
you just start to kind of reward people
don't like to be challenged
and that's sort of the the other big
problem with social media
that is also affecting the big news
organizations is
and this is something tristan harris
talked about we're optimizing
social media is optimizing for outrage
it's optimizing for any kind of response
that keeps you kind of engaged and
outraged
righteous outrage outrage porn and what
he calls the race to the bottom of the
brain stem
like we're bypassing our kind of cortex
we're going directly to kind of like the
limbic system
and kind of like getting into a fight or
flight kind of mode because it because
it rewards engagement it gets you kind
of into a i can't believe they said that
i'm going to do that
and that's happening to to the big
players as well as the small players
yeah and at the bottom of it it's a
death of nuance
yeah where what we see now is every
media outlet
with exception of a small selection it's
just advocacy media
yeah you know what they're going to say
before they say it so this is what i was
trying to get out earlier with my
question david
because you talked about where we are
now sub stack and all that sort of thing
but there was something that happened
before that there was something that
happened that by
2014 15 people in the media
decided that their job was not
the reason that you're no longer welcome
at channel 4
the pursuit of truth their job was
activism their job was to stop brexit
let's say or to stop donald trump being
elected or
to stop remain or whatever it was their
job
was to campaign and so when we talk
about you know
the the new york times versus
alternative the only thing
that i see is a distinction and yes
we're all subject to the same
pressures and pulling and driving
factors
people like us don't pretend that we're
neutral
kathy newman pretended in that interview
to be neutral
while not being neutral to put it very
mildly
right and that is a change that i don't
know and i was curious to ask you about
it because you were a journalist
in that world for a long time when did
that
shift happen maybe we're just making it
up maybe you're thinking
the good old days that never actually
existed and everybody was always
partisan we've always had
a partisan media in this country we have
newspapers that are right when we have
newspapers they're left-wing
am i idolizing the past here by saying
it wasn't always like this
no i think there was a shift that some
when
i can kind of remember it because i
think that that shift is also connected
to social media
so i think one of the things that the
growth of alternative media has done is
shown up the bias of the mainstream yeah
like before there was this kind of like
objective view from nowhere
voice from nowhere affectation that
increasingly is obviously like oh that's
a that's a thing that's a that's a game
and it's obviously kind of it's it's
more and more transparent that that's
going on
but there was a there was a time where
the the anchors for example or the
reporters at channel 4 news or any of
the
the big news organizations were allowed
to have
their own perspective but there were a
lot they were increasingly kind of
liberal liberalized rules around you're
allowed to kind of
campaign on twitter you're allowed to
have a you're allowed to have a persona
that's not just
um that's not just purely independent so
i think there was a there was a
deliberate and i think a probably
a a valid
decision made at some points by kind of
the editors to say
okay this we we need them to compete in
this in this kind of information economy
so therefore that we're going to have to
allow them some more limited some more
freedoms on social media to kind of have
their own opinions
and that definitely happened quite a
while ago but there are still different
regulations as to what you're allowed to
do on screen versus what you're allowed
to do in social media
so there's almost and that's another
part of the problem is there's no
offcom regulation of something like like
youtube there's no regulation of stuff
like
like twitter and i think they kind of
adapted to that by saying yes you're
allowed to kind of campaign on these
different issues
um whereas there are still offcom and
there are still there is still
regulation on
especially on broadcast news in the uk
in a way that there isn't
in the us but yeah i think they did
actually make a specific decision to say
no we've got to compete in this kind of
information economy and now we're going
to take the shackles off in terms of
what you're allowed to say and we've now
moved into
the social media world the where
everybody has got a slice of the pie or
at least a chance
of a slice of the pie but that very much
produces
its own challenges its own problems
which
let's be fair we are all wrestling with
everybody in this room is wrestling with
you know we're trying to figure out as
we go along walk to you with the very
real challenges and problems
that we face as creators yeah
and i think that's a really good way of
framing it because
we are all subject to these same things
we're all wrestling with this
in in many different ways um
like i certainly for
as someone who's got a youtube channel
i'm very aware
like i wish i was less aware of like the
comments for example like
caring what the comments think i know we
talked and you guys said you're less
worried about it because of your comedy
background you're kind of used to being
kind of heckled and people but i feel
that as a kind of like
and i don't want to i don't want to kind
of feel that as a but i'm
it's like i've got an eye in the back of
my head i kind of know what they want
what they don't want and
i tried to not let that affect me and i
do put out things i know are going to
challenge
the audience and i'm quite i'm getting
more and more comfortable with doing
that but i know that that's
something i don't feel entirely
comfortable with there's also a set of
kind of
aligned incentives and
like one of the things like i really
enjoyed the interview that we had and
i've tried to do sort of
i've tried to follow like the truth of
um
when i think there are challenging
questions to ask someone i'll i'll ask
those challenging questions
but it's it's a difficult place to be in
in this alternative media universe
because
if you get yourself a reputation as
someone who's just a difficult character
then it's not if i was working at
channel 4 news or working for one of the
big organizations
i'd be able to do that and i'd have the
the organization behind me people would
still say yes to the interview whereas
if you get yourself a kind of reputation
as being
too challenging and the alternative
people just say no we're not going to do
an interview with you
my central worry is i think that we've
got a dysfunctional system we've got
the old system of of the kind of what
some people call the blue
church media establishment that was
increasingly dysfunctional in many ways
but still had a set of checks and
balances still had a sense of like
free speech without the ideas being
tested for me is not free speech
free speech is a prerequisite for then
the idea is being tested in the
in the marketplace of ideas and what i
see coming along in the alternative
environments we've gone away from one
system we're kind of we might at some
point
have a decentralized way of approaching
truth
right now i think we're in this kind of
no man's land where
a lot of the alternative narratives are
not showing up in the
in the mainstream but they're not being
challenged in the alternative as well
and i think the system's like really
broken i know we we talked
um we did a series of films about london
real earlier in the great game
great guy yeah about how much i admire
brian rose and
um love you brian yeah love him uh two
percent i think he's got in
uh for the london mayor campaign but um
so
actually he's just grouped with the
others in three percent
um but yeah i mean the reason i was
interested in that
story was because he had on david ike at
the beginning of the
of the pandemic david i'm sorry to
interrupt i'm just aware uh
the channel we're talking about uh used
to be a youtube channel did interviews
with people and then when the pandemic
hit they started doing conspiracy stuff
basically yeah
yeah yeah that's a good summary they had
on david ike
at the beginning of the pandemic he said
covered as a hoax
it's caused by 5g kind of if you don't
take matters into your own hands then
life as itself
will be over youtube took that down
quite quite rightly i think
but he then embarked on this quite
cynical
like bringing on a lot of conspiracy
people
not challenging them and i and it was
very successful he got a lot of views
for it
he started this kind of digital freedom
platform thing the way he
kind of raised a load of money for it
and what if what
set me or what kind of i was really
concerned about was like okay you've got
these alternative narratives like being
arising and no one's challenging them
like there's a huge audience for them
and they're not being reflected in the
mainstream at all which is kind of
increasingly
you could argue increasingly conformist
and then you've got the alternative
narratives and they're just
they're just thriving because they're
getting views and no they're not being
challenged
and that i was also interested with
london real because he was kind of using
this like
free speech argument and that for me was
really
like free speech is such a sacred value
that if you're going to use it you're
going to exploit it for your own
purposes i think that's really really
dangerous
and if the ideas are not being tested
in the marketplace for me it's not it's
not really free speech
and that's where i think that's why i
think our interview is really
interesting as well because i think
these are
there's huge nuances you can talk about
free speech versus censorship and no
censorship
but then you've got the question like
who are you inviting on to interview how
are you doing that interview
how are you promoting that interview is
this person's
views being challenged elsewhere even if
not by you than by other people and that
for me is like where
i see this um yeah there's sort of
it's breaking down everywhere like the
the way of challenging truth and finding
truth i think is breaking down
everywhere
which is in the mainstream but also in
the alternative
as well do you not think that we maybe
think of ourselves as a full replacement
for the mainstream media where really
what we should be thinking about is
well if you want this perspective you
come and watch trigonometry
and if you want to see that perspective
challenge there'll be other channels
that will provide that rather than
thinking that it's the job of rebel
wisdom or the job of trigonometry
to provide you with the full range of
opinions because frankly
it's not going to happen for reasons to
do with financial
technical staffing and also we don't
have the resources
or frankly the ability to attract every
type of guest that we'd like because
the way that it works in the alternative
media spaces once you've had
exxon then why won't come on your show
because they don't think of you the same
way that they would think of channel
four where
you can have jordan peterson on today
and a massive
woke feminist on the next day just
doesn't work that way in our space and
so
to expect you or i or francis to be able
to do that
is unrealistic in the first place yeah i
think we all have to make our own
follow our own conscience in terms of
the people that we're having on and
how we're doing those interviews and i
do think i mean just just the sheer
size and scope like we don't have the
ability to
to to kind of do a proper news job
and even so like we're mostly i'd say
we're mostly kind of commentary
opinion rather than kind of i've done a
couple of like investigations and sort
of what i consider like primary news
stuff but they're
few and far between yeah most of the
time i think we're doing interviews and
we're shedding light on the stories
rather than
um but i mean the point that we that we
kind of clashed on in our interview
before was about
the interview with with uh sushi right
back tea and whether
putting on someone who was critical of
the vaccine meant that you had an
obligation to put on someone who was pro
vaccine yeah i mean that's an open
question i wasn't i was asking that as a
question as to whether
that that for me and that in the end for
me comes down to
an individual conscience thing and
then being aware of like what's the
drive why am i doing certain things
am i doing this just for the just for
the sort of the amount of views which is
always going to be a fact i mean we're
not going to put on interviews that get
no views i mean
that's always going to be a factor but
then is that is that warping my decision
of who to get on
do i feel an integrity in the way that
that has that's happened
do i feel i've got the the amount of
intel um
background of research to be able to
challenge this person to be able to
to be able to evaluate their claims all
of that sort of stuff
um but it depends what your objective is
as well like for me
i think i've still got a very um
strong set of i don't know principles
that i kind of built up over
say 20 years doing journalism that maybe
aren't even appropriate for the new
alternative world that's a that's a kind
of inquiry i'm
i'm involved in um but i do there's a
few people who are really wrestling with
this question quite deeply a friend of
mine daniel schmacktenberger is putting
together something called the
consilience project where he's trying to
do like really high level
um almost like kind of
secret service briefing level analysis
of
of issues of the news because that's
what he thinks is needed like we need
that there's an imbalance because a lot
of the the most
a lot of the most high quality
information is being gathered by
people who are researching for hedge
funds people are researching for
uh security services like those and
a lot of that doesn't necessarily filter
down into the mainstream media so he's
saying this is an imbalance which allows
some people to exploit
the world um become rich at other
people's expense and what we need to do
democratize that like really high level
information
getting so so i do think there are
people but but this is a project that's
costing several million pounds to put
together
and it's going to be involving kind of
employing a lot of people i think
we're we we just don't have the capacity
to do that sort of thing
but it's all in it's a great point but
there's also the issue of challenging
like people always go
to us and the criticism that we face all
the time is you don't
challenge your guests enough and then
you talk about what does that actually
mean to challenge someone
and a lot of the thomas is like oh they
said something seven or eight years ago
why haven't you brought that up in an
interview and i i would love to know
what your position on that is as a
trained journalist
is that challenging is that just always
challenging
does that mean something else what does
challenging mean to you challenging an
idea
i would say it depends on the per
depends on who it is
i i would generally
say yes like if there is someone who
said who's made a comment or
has kind of had a disgrace in the past
like if this is the main thing that
people know about them for example
then i would say yes you probably do
need to bring that up in the interview
to say
look you said this thing a while ago do
you still think that
do you regret saying that i think there
is an obligation to give
background so that the audience are able
to make up their minds on who this
person is what they think
especially if um i mean there's some
people
who i think if you're not doing that
you're doing a disservice to the
audience by not bringing it up
i can think of some various kind of
pretty if someone's controversial
i don't think i mean one of the one of
the kind of criticisms
oh you shouldn't have a conversation
with that person and that's often done
it's like the guilt by association thing
and that
for me is just that's an old tactic by
the kind of media and that's trying to
put
that's trying to put the genie back in
the bottle and that's not gonna it's not
gonna work
like we've got an infinite number of
media channels so that that whole guilt
by association thing is a game that
won't
that won't work anymore but i do think
that there is
for me i feel like i feel a certain
obligation to
if someone's controversial to explain in
the conversation why they're
controversial
just say you you caused a real
controversy a while ago when you said
this and this
what was that about did you do you
regret yeah do you regret that
what was the context for it um and for
me
the danger is that a lot of this becomes
performative and i think people are
really sick and tired with the
performative nature of
a lot of legacy media because the
journalist isn't really oriented towards
finding truth what they're oriented
towards is signaling to other
journalists
signaling to everyone else that they're
still on their side and that this
person's beyond the pale for this reason
and this reason and this reason which
was
i mean the kathy newman jordan peterson
she was the perfect kind of like that
was the
apotheosis of that kind of way of
interacting it's like
and i think everyone looks at it and
they're like this isn't how normal
people
talk to each other and the interesting
thing is that now in the alternative
media when you look at joe rogan and you
look at kind of these
people who've made their livings out of
an alternative long-form conversation
you're like they're talking to
each other like people talk to each
other yeah and this kind of performative
thing is
is just it's it's an old way of you're
not react you're not even relating to
that person as a person
like you're relating to them as
something else like you're relating to
them
as an it you're not relating to them as
a as someone that you can have a
interaction and a connection with um
and i think joe rogan is a good example
because
i've seen him do really informative
challenging interviews
on some fairly controversial people he
he did a really good job with stefan
molyneux
for example he's a kind of pretty
controversial kind of race realist
type and if you look at the interview
that he did he he'd done a lot of
research on that he
he brought up some pretty um
critical and suspect things that he'd
said in the past that he'd done in the
past the nature of the organization that
he kind of created
and joe rogan despite kind of being a
by his own admission being a sort of
meat head who's just like talking to
people and then found himself in this
role that he never expected
i think he's really kind of grown into
that
and i see a lot of responsibility
in the way that he does his interviews i
think he did a very interesting one with
candace owens as well that was
you compare that to the one that dave
rubin did with candice owens like it was
a really different kind of kind of
interview
and i felt like she she struggled
with a few of the follow-ups um
so i think there is a way of doing it i
think you need to avoid being stuck in
like the performative
mainstream like i'm just doing this to
signal to everyone else that i'm a good
person you're a bad person
game and the other side of i'm never
going to ask
anyone a difficult question or i'm never
i'm just going to let them speak
i think there's a midpoint that that
we're still evolving towards i think
we're all still kind of learning what
that is i think it also changes with
how powerful you experience yourself to
be if you have a show with 10 million
subscribers
you are not afraid to piss off your
guests if you haven't
also there's more pressure on you from
like this is the other thing i think joe
rogan is under scrutiny from youtube and
from
the like i think he he is also slightly
forced to do that
i think that's why he doesn't have
certain guests on because
people take notice of who he puts on
yeah so i think that's the other weird
thing is that the journalistic
obligations grow as your channel grows
in a way at the moment
as well yeah and you know i think we all
experience it i think the bigger we get
the more
we but but also you know the problem is
as well is
a lot of us who are doing this don't
have any journalistic training
right so we don't we feel our way
through the whole thing
uh but actually i wanted to come back to
your thing about comments because i
think this is a really important
conversation to have and
rogan is you know he's got his way of
dealing with it which he says just don't
read it which i
i don't buy uh i don't you don't think
he doesn't read them
i don't think he doesn't read them
number one and we've seen some evidence
of that his first interview with jack
dorsey for example was a good example
yeah he did an interview jack dorsey got
a [ __ ] ton of pushback
and suddenly bam jack dorsey was back on
the show with temple and vijaya gad
yeah being grilled right yeah so that's
a perfect example yeah
so he first of all he does read the
comments uh
clearly or someone does for him but the
other thing as well is
you know you talk about how the comments
affect you
and we as comedians are less of i
as i said on your show we have a
tremendous amount of respect for our
audience
we really do but at the same time i
don't even
believe that the comments under this
video
are necessarily from the fans of the
show what will often happen with an
interview
is you'll get people coming along who
either love or hate your guests who
don't follow your show
and who comment on that video and
actually you know
one of france's uh ex-girlfriend said
this she said
have you ever commented on a youtube
video do you know anyone who's ever
commented on a youtube video
so the fact that 10 people or 100 people
even a thousand people who've left some
comments under this video right now
a representative of our audience
to me is a complete misnomer because
very often what you'll have is
uh loads of people upload a video very
few down vote
and yet all the comments are negative
and you're going that doesn't make any
sense and the reality is
you know people who who comment are the
people who feel the strongest perhaps
that's one interpretation does that mean
that that's representative of the public
reaction to an interview i don't think
so
so to me yes there's some gold
to be dug out of that but you have to
recognize that it's not representative
of the audience
and that's why you know uh peterson and
rogan
to me are inspirational in that way even
though i have disagreements with both of
those men on many things
uh the the way that they have inspired
me is the way i think about it is
well i'm gonna ask you a question that i
find interesting
and i'm to trust that there's an
audience out there
that is also interested in the answer to
that question you know
and i think that's an approach that
does that mean that this channel was a
result will be
neutral and unbiased well of course not
because i'm biased and so is francis and
so are you
but at least it's honest right it's then
honest i'm asking the question that i
really want to ask you
and i think that's maybe where the
answer lies to some extent
is just to go what's the question i want
to ask you and
let's find out what you want to say
about it um so yeah
an audience capture is a thing that i
think a lot of people are concerned
about it but it
i i don't think audience capture and
allowing yourself to be captured by the
audience will ever work
actually in the long run it's a very
poor long-term strategy it also depends
who you're
i think you're right i think the
comments often are the most
reactive the most triggered people
who've seen that particular thing
and they're often not representative of
so we have
um a membership like we we've got about
a thousand
members of of rebel wisdom and the
conversation with them
is so different from the conversation
that goes on in the in the comments
and i i think that's because we've put
out a lot of different films over a long
time and i know kind of what sort of
background a lot of them come from
i think if you have and that is far is
a far bigger um influence
if your biggest patreon subscribers
or supporters have a certain perspective
then i think that starts to warp it a
little bit more and it depends who
they are it depends like who are the
people who are most attracted to your
content who are the ones who are willing
to pay for it
who are the ones like especially if
you've got like really high value
tiers like say you know we have we had
quite a high value one at one time and
we got rid of it
i think that starts to have a real
impact on you if you're
and if you're framing your if you're
framing your show in a certain way and
you attract a lot of people that
like i'm very glad with the audience
that that we have like that
for me act as a kind of dampener on
where if we were to sort of um take the
comments too seriously because i know
that
there's a much more considered group of
people who have invested more time and
more energy and more money
in in supporting us and we we have the
same thing i mean you
this the whole financial side of this is
very interesting because uh
we are sitting here recording this in
mid-march
uh we probably lost about
10 to 15 of our
income that we had from subscribers in
the last couple of months
because we came out very strongly uh
when the whole trump thing capital thing
happened
and we were very clear about our view on
that and deliberately so
because we know that the core audience
that we have are people who are
interested in sensible balanced
conversation
uh and if that means that over time
those ups and those downs
we'll live with that you know are you
sure that that's was the
reason yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and so and that's and that's fine by us
you know i think
i think that's another so someone i
think who does that
whether you agree with him or not about
certain things sam harris i think is
someone who
deliberately goes out of his way to kind
of speak out and to cast off
some of his audience like he he talks a
lot about islam
but he will say things deliberately to
to kind of
avoid islamophobes becoming sort of like
oh he's on our side so he'll say things
to deliberately piss off
and um i guess to
whittle away at the people that he
doesn't want following him or doesn't
want influencing him
and i think that's essential it's like
um the great artists
of what you think of david bowie or
someone like that who constantly changes
like because you get trapped like david
bowie sort of does a um
what is it space oddity gets people who
just want more space quality it's like
no no i'm an artist they're going to
completely reinvent each time
and i think that's the kind of thing as
soon as you put out something that then
attracts a certain people who want you
to do a certain thing
then you'll stop you're stopping
evolving you're stopping growing and
stopping kind of
doing following your own inner sort of
um sense of exploration and you start
kind of responding to
to what you want from or what the
audience wants from you which i'm sure
you get in comedy as well all the time
people are just sort of
mining themselves and repeating
themselves it just feels like tired and
pandering yeah pandering
exhausting after a while but it's also
one of the things that i never expected
when doing this
is the struggles that you have with your
own morality
where you actually thinking about
inviting a guest for instance we had
nigel farage on
which went out a few weeks ago and then
reflecting on that and you're thinking
to yourself did i challenge them enough
should i have brought up that comment
was it the right thing to get nigel
farage on
why did i get them on and that constant
process of self-examination that
actually
if you're a journalist working at
channel 4 you don't
have to ask yourself those questions
you do and you don't i mean you the
other thing is that you're constantly
in a dialogue with your editors or with
different level different sort of layers
of management and different people
around you in the newsroom
so it's generally a kind of it's
generally a pitch that then is approved
or disapproved by someone so there's a
there's more people involved in that um
conversation but there would be like if
you're going to get nicer farage on
there
there'll be a conversation about why
we're getting him on how are we getting
him on what are we going to ask him
about what are the things that he needs
to respond to or
um so yeah but there is a sort of
institutional protection as well that in
a way it's not just your decision
where when when you do that with a
channel for news or with one of the
big organizations i'd just like to
reassure everybody at home that the
morality question in france francis
talked about i don't have that
but david it's been great chatting with
you thanks for coming on the show i
think we
explored stuff and normally we interview
the guests
but this time we had more of a
conversation which i really enjoyed
and as you know we've got one final
question for you which is always
what's the one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be obviously
i knew you're gonna ask this
i was thinking about it this morning um
i was kind of i went down a little bit
of a rabbit hole with the question
because
i think everything is being because you
can talk about
other there's there's lots of topics
that are not being talked about in the
mainstream and should be
but there will be other places where
they are being talked about and that's
and i think that's my biggest sense the
thing that we're not talking about is
the fact that
all of these topics are being talked
about in different ecosystems
and they're not coming together but that
for me is the crucial
the fragmentation of the information
landscape
the fragmentation of well some people i
mean these are
these are kind of uh these are kind of
very pompous words but
the fragmentation of the epistemic
commons is something that um
people on our channel have talked about
quite a lot the
the fact that sense making is becoming
so difficult
because of the nature of filter bubbles
because of the nature of social media
um because we're basically being served
up
more of what we already think like
that's the real
tragedy is that we're being locked in
and we're not really aware of it we're
not
because it's being warped around us
we're not being aware of the fact that
it's actually easier and better for
these big
incredibly powerful algorithms driven by
some of the
fine by the most kind of sophisticated
technology we have
are just building these like prisons
around ourselves
and all of the all of them are just
basically basically keeping us what we
already know it's like
oh yeah we already hate those we still
hate those more outraged porn about how
the other side are crazy the other side
are wrong
and this sense that those bubbles are
getting further and further away from
each other
and so i think what are we not talking
about we're not
any subject that i can say we're not
talking about
is being talked about somewhere in some
bubbles and there's ecosystems that grow
around like
even like forbidden truths that the
mainstream are not talking about but
then there's a danger there because that
becomes another
ecosystem that isn't challenged as well
so then
so that's my that would be my answer to
that i think an understanding of
how fragmented we are how
broken the system is for coming together
and connecting with each other
and the fact that social media is kind
of
weaponized i'll use this one example
because i think it's really really
useful
so jonathan heights work and i know
you're familiar with jonathan height
amazing social psychologist who talks
about why good people are divided by
politics and religion
says that a lot of our views are
essentially temperamental
conservatives tend to tend to rate
higher in order
liberals higher in openness and and the
reason for that is that we need
different
proclivities we need different
temperaments we're effective in tribes
that's how we've evolved to be effective
in tribes
and what social media is doing to us is
weaponizing those temperaments against
each other
and then we're tribalizing based on
those temperaments
and that's an existential crisis like
we're basically
doing this incredible experiment on
ourselves and
it's a temporary it's a yeah i don't
think we quite
realize the danger of that the fact that
we are kind of
tribalizing ourselves in a way that
could be
a um a civilizational threat
and so that's the thing i think is being
talked about and i think the the
documentary the social dilemma
on netflix is a real first step and i
think we're starting to kind of have a
conversation around
oh well in the same way that we started
talking about smoking being really
dangerous i think we're now starting to
realize that social media is dangerous
but i don't think people realize
quite how dangerous it is and quite how
because
because it's changing the nature of
everything we're perceiving like we're
all in different worlds
and you can't you can't run a society
if you can't agree on what's true you
can't how can you solve any of the
problems in the world
whatever they are if you can't agree on
that their problems
but there's so many different views on
climate change there's so many different
views on so many of these major issues
so until we figure out how to fix the
information landscape
we're not going to make progress on
anything else
and on that upbeat note thank you very
much david for coming on the show
if people want to find you online or on
social media where is the best place to
do that
uh rebel wisdom uh follow me on twitter
check out rebelwisdom um and check out
the interview that we did together
because i think it was a really good
interview
and i i've picked you up at the
beginning so i'll big you up now
yeah i was really really pleased with
the the conversation we had and
walking the walk on free speech and
longmaier continuing thanks for coming
on dave
uh make sure to follow the links will be
in the description of the video
uh thanks for watching and we will see
you very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one
or a live stream take care and see you
soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below